Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum 15. Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Marc Sackop-Ost und ich behandle heute hier ein besonderes Thema. Und deshalb starten wir auch ohne die bekannte Musik einfach nur so.
Es ist einfach so, dass ich kein richtiges Vertrauen auch mehr in meinen Knie habe und ich nicht halbherzig spielen kann. Das kann ich – was heißt halbherzig? aber ich kann keine halben Sachen machen. Und wenn es zur Qual wird und das war es in letzter Zeit, dann muss ich einfach entscheiden und das habe ich getan.
Ein Stück mehr Menschlichkeit, ein Stück mehr Zivilcourage, ein Stück mehr Bekenntnis zur Würde des Menschen, des Nächsten, des Anderen. Das wird Robert Enke gerichtet. Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Wo sind Sie hingegangen, wenn Sie das Gefühl hatten, ich muss jetzt mal schwach sein?
Ja, ich habe das leider für mich behalten. Ich habe dann versucht, die Schwachmomente zu überspielen, um für andere stark zu wirken. Und das hat leider auch dazu geführt, dass ich dann quasi so tief abgerutscht bin, wie es dann passiert ist. Im Nachhinein wäre es besser gewesen, sich an vertrauten Menschen zu eröffnen. Vielleicht hätte es dann eine schnellere, bessere Lösung gegeben.
Kann man das irgendwie erklären, warum psychische Erkrankungen sich so verbreiten in unserer jetzigen Zeit? Man liest da immer viele Allgemeinplätze vom Druck, der auf jedem herrschen würde, von der Arbeitsbelastung, die wir alle haben, von der ständigen Bombardierung mit neuen Nachrichten, also auch dem, dass man das Ruhezeiten manchmal fehlen. Ich tue mich ehrlich gesagt aber immer schwer, mit so allgemeinen Gesellschaftsbeobachtungen dann so etwas zu unterfüttern, wie dass eine psychische Krankheit sich so zur Volkskrankheit entwickeln wird, auch in der Zukunft.
Die ist schon eine Volkskrankheit und sie ist durch alle Zeiten hin mal mehr, mal weniger präsent und wir werden sie auch nicht komplett verhindern können. Ich glaube, wichtig ist einfach, dass man in der Tat die Sache nicht schlimmer macht als sie ist, dass nicht noch gesellschaftliche Situationen da sind, die einen größeren sozialen Druck verursachen, größere Stressfaktoren verursachen, dass dadurch noch eine höhere Rate von Depressionen eine Rolle spielt. Aber im Wesentlichen wird es eine Depression immer geben. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich wichtig zu akzeptieren, dass Krankheiten sind, dass diese Krankheiten aber behandelbar sind, dass wir Leute aufmerksam sind, auch mit ihren Angehörigen. Wir erleben das ganz häufig, dass Personen sich nicht selber auf eigenen Wunsch vorstellen, sondern dass die Ehepartner, Eltern, Kinder sagen oder jemanden dazu bewegen, sich dann doch letztlich eine Therapie zu begeben. So ist es auch manchmal bei Sportlern. Dass dann der Trainer oder die Partner sich melden und sagen, komm, geh doch mal, hol dir Hilfe. Dass wir alle um unsere wichtigsten Bezugspersonen auch ein bisschen achtsamer sind. Ich glaube, das kann schon helfen, dass vielleicht nicht eine Depression verhindert wird, aber doch, dass eine Behandlung zum Beispiel eher eingeleitet werden kann.
Jetzt gibt es seit der Saison 2015 und seit 2016 in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren der 2. und 3. Liga muss es einen Pädagogen in Vollzeit und einen Psychologen in Teilzeit geben. Herr Reng, wie sind denn die Bundesliga-Vereine in dem Bereich aufgestellt? Man liest immer viel von Mental-Coaches. Da würde ich jetzt aber erstmal die Frage in den Raum stellen, ob das dann immer auch gleich Psychologen oder Psychotherapeuten sind, die sowas auch diagnostizieren könnten.
Ja, das ist erstmal ein grundlegender Unterschied. Also der Sportpsychologe – und ich glaube, mittlerweile sind es in den meisten Fällen bei den Bundesliga tatsächlich ausgebildete Psychologen – ist ja in erster Linie zur Leistungsoptimierung, das moderne Wort, und Steigerung da. Also da geht es nicht darum, Krankheiten zu erkennen oder gar zu therapieren. Der kann das auch gar nicht therapieren. Dazu braucht es einen Psychotherapeuten oder einen Psychiater dann. Aber ein gut ausgebildeter Psychologe und auch ein Psychologe, wie man sich ihn vorstellt, mit großer Empathie, der hat im Idealfall natürlich ein besseres Auge als der Assistenttrainer für diese Krankheiten. Aber wie gesagt, der ist nicht dafür da. Das wäre im besten Fall ein Nebenprodukt, wenn der auch nochmal eine Depression erkennt oder eine psychische Krankheit und sie dann in die richtige Wege leitet, den Jungen zur Behandlung schickt. Aber darum geht es da nicht in dem Fall. Es ist eine große Diskussion auch unter Psychiatern und Psychotherapeuten, die im Sport arbeiten. Sollte auch der Sportpsychiater beim Verein angestellt sein? Sollte es so eine Position geben? Oder sollte der eben gerade nicht beim Verein angestellt sein? Weil in dem Moment, wo er beim Verein angestellt ist, er ja Teil dieses Systems ist und es vielleicht dem Sportler dann schwerfällt, zu dem Psychiater eines Vereins zu gehen, weil er dann das Gefühl hätte, naja, der hat zwar die Schweigepflicht, aber ich weiß nicht, was sagt er nicht doch dem Trainer? Also das ist bei manche denken, es ist besser, wie es jetzt ist, dass der Sportpsychiater außerhalb ist, dass der Sportler das Gefühl hat, er kann da hingehen und das alles ist weit weg und bleibt weg von dem Club. Während es andere Sportpsychiater gibt, die sagen, doch sie müssten näher dran sein, sie müssten auch Teil des Vereins sein, weil sie dann auch eben viel schneller und viel besser Krankheitsfälle erkennen können. Das ist ein Streit, eine Debatte klingt nicht so schlimm wie Streitfall unter den Sportpsychiatern selber. Es gibt aber, um das abzuschließen, soweit ich weiß, in keinem Fußballverein der Welt einen festangestellten Sportpsychiater, sondern es gibt diesen Psychologen, der durchaus auch mit psychischen Problemen wie Angstzustände, da kann er versuchen, daran zu arbeiten, die kann er abzustellen. Aber Depressionen erkennt er im besten Fall und überweist dann zum Kollegen.
Und hat das auch mit dem Bild des Sportlers zu tun, was sich so immer aufgebaut hat? Also im Fußball besonders noch der männliche, starke, der keine Schwächen zeigen darf, ein bisschen Draufgänger soll er sein, auch ein bisschen genial am liebsten, darf auch mal über die Stränge schlagen und muss aber auf dem Platz ordentlich hinlangen. Müsste man auch so ein bisschen das Bild des Sportlers, das man in Medien und vor allem in den Medien zeichnet, überdenken, um ein besseres Umfeld zu schaffen, wo mehr Verständnis für auch Kopfkrankheiten herrscht, das ist jetzt ein sehr banaler Begriff dafür, was ich meine, was ja aber als Schwäche gesehen wird. Also ein gebrochenes Bein ist ein gebrochenes Bein, da kann ich, doof gesagt, nichts für. Eine Depression, da sagen die Leute ja, jetzt habt ich doch bitte nicht so.
Naja, man muss ja erstmal festhalten, dass auf dem Fußballplatz und in dieser Klasse oder mit dieser Klasse, mit der heute Fußball gespielt wird, da kann man sich da in der Tat kaum noch Fehler und sozusagen Schwächen erlauben. Und aufgrund dieser Perfektion, die das Spiel auch erreicht hat, und wir feiern ja im Fernsehen, wir zeigen ja im Fernsehen eigentlich nur das Spiel und wir zeigen Schnipsel von Emotionen nach dem Spiel, indem wir verschwitzte Fußballer interviewen. Also da wird in diesen 90 Minuten plus Nachspielzeit natürlich das Bild des Zuschauers vom Sportler geprägt. Und da sehen wir in der Tat Sportler, die scheinbar auf dem Rasen frei von Schwächen sind. Und das Publikum schafft es oder will es auch gar nicht offenbar, umzuschwitzen und zu sagen, das sind aber trotzdem noch Menschen. Und in dem Moment, als sie vom Platz runtergehen, in dem Moment, wo sie ihr Berufsfeld, das sie auf fabelhafter Weise beherrschen, in dem Moment, in dem sie es verlassen, haben die selbstverständlich Sorgen, Ängste, Schwächen und auch psychische Krankheiten oder psychische Probleme wie andere auch. Dieser eigentlich ganz banale Transfer, dieser Gedanke, der findet nicht statt, weil wir in der Tat, wir oder das Publikum Sportler braucht, offenbar zum Ausgleich vom echten Leben. Also Sportler sind keine Figuren mehr aus dem echten Leben, sondern das sind die Figuren, wenn wir, dass die Zuschauer abschalten vom echten Leben und deswegen gestehen wir denen auch gar nicht mehr zu, dass sie Menschen sind wie wir. Wir wollen die überhöhen, wir wollen die sehen als fabelhafte Gladiatoren, fantastische Figuren einer Traumwelt von 90 Minuten, in der man seine Gefühle extrem ausleben kann. Verlieren, man weint, man schreit, man gewinnt, man fühlt sich endlich als Sieger. Und deswegen haben das Publikum, glaube ich, oder das Großteil des Publikums gar kein großes Interesse daran, den Sportler als Mensch kennenzulernen. Während ich vielleicht, was mein Job ist als Buchschreiber, erlebe, dass gerade Sportler, immer mehr Sportler eine große Sehnsucht danach haben, endlich mal alles zu erzählen. Also Andrew Agassi zum Beispiel, die Biografie, die er geschrieben hat. Und da gibt es ganz viele Sportler mittlerweile, die das Gefühl haben, die das Instinktiv vom Publikum übernommen haben. Diese Rolle, die sie spielen sollen, des Unverletzlichen. Sie meinen, sie müssten sich so geben, weil das erwartet wird. Und die aber dann das Gefühl haben, sie müssten etwas in sich reinfressen. Sie müssen etwas verbergen. Das ist völlig falsche Gefühl. Sie können eigentlich nie sie sein. Die also unbewusst übernehmen, den Glauben, sie müssten auch außerhalb des Platzes dieser unverwundbare Gladiator sein. Und irgendwann brechen da einige zusammen – oder eine Zusammenbrechung klingt schon wieder zu dramatisch – haben den Wunsch, einfach mal alles rauszuschreien und sich tatsächlich zu offenbaren, wie sie wirklich sind mit ihren Schwächen. Das passiert dann in Dokumentarfilmen oder in Biografien. Aber da erleben wir ja, dass das Publikum deutlich weniger diese Filme anschaut oder diese Biografien kauft, indem wirklich ohne Fassade einfach mal der Alltag auch erzählt wird. Sondern das Publikum will abschalten und das schafft es, benutzt den Sport als Mittel zum Abschalten und zieht deswegen nur diese 90 Minuten, interessieren ihn.
Ich denke, was auch eine Rolle spielt, ist, dass Sportler natürlich sehr disziplinierte Menschen sind. Jemand, der so viel – häufig wird ja die ganze Jugend und die ganze Freizeit in den Sport gesteckt. Häufig sind auch Familienmitglieder, die das pushen oder sich selber da auch eine Aufgabe schaffen. Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass es alles in gewisser Weise auch sehr kontrollierte Menschen sind, die natürlich eigentlich auch andere Bedürfnisse haben, aber sich nach außen hin natürlich sehr, sehr kontrolliert geben. Und gerade, wenn man zum Mannschaftssport geht, dann wird das ja auch nach außen gelebt. Wir sind eine Einheit und wir sind alles Freunde. Das wird sicherlich nicht so sein. Aber ich glaube, das kriegt jemand, der sich von Kindesbeinen an intensiv mit Sport beschäftigt und da Teil des Ganzen ist, natürlich auch so ein bisschen eingeimpft. Und ich glaube, deswegen haben wir häufig natürlich auch mit Personen zu tun, die so diesen Part, dieses Disziplinierte, dieses Strebsame schon internalisiert haben. Was aber nicht heißen muss, dass die emotionale Entwicklung irgendwie im gleichen Maße ist. Also wenn man mit Sportlern zu tun hat, hat man häufig sogar so eine gewisse Diskrepanz zwischen dem einerseits sehr nach außen Erwachsenen und diszipliniert wirkenden, vernünftig wirkenden Menschen. Andererseits aber so was wie eine, da fehlt es manchmal an anderen Aspekten, wie Organisationen, also die geben dann manches ab an ihr Umfeld und an andere, die sie organisieren und aber selber sich sozusagen eine normale Entwicklung nicht machen konnten. Und dann wird zumindest dann, wenn das Unterstützungssystem mal wegfällt oder wenn der Sport mal vorbei ist, geben sich dann neue Probleme. Wenn dann plötzlich man sozusagen auf eigenen Beinen stehen muss, aber bestimmte Skills so im Leben noch nicht erlernt hat.
Diese sehr hohe Disziplin, über die Sportler verfügen, war bei Robert Enke auch ein Fluch und Segen innerhalb seiner Depression, weil er zum einen, obwohl er von dieser Krankheit sehr gezeichnet war mit den Symptomen, dass er sich die ganze Zeit gestresst gefühlt hat, morgens eigentlich nicht mehr aus dem Bett wollte, trotzdem hat ihn die Disziplin immer noch funktionieren lassen als Fußballer. Er ist immer noch zum Training gefahren und konnte immer noch, obwohl er auch Antidepressiva genommen hat, konnte er noch so trainieren, dass es offenbar in seiner Mannschaft niemanden auffiel, dass er unter einer schweren Krankheit litt. Und das war einerseits natürlich gut für ihn. Er konnte sozusagen den Alltag aufrechterhalten, war aber vielleicht dann irgendwo auch dann doch der Fluch, weil er sich in Behandlung begeben, rausgehen aus dem Fußball und sich sechs Wochen, drei Monate, sechs Monate, wie lange es dauert, behandeln lassen. Diesen Schritt, zu dem wurde er nie gezwungen von seinem Körper, weil er irgendwie immer den Körper noch mit seiner Disziplin überlisten konnte und weiter funktioniert hatte. Das wäre im Nachhinein sicher für ihn besser gewesen, wenn er aufgegeben hätte und sich behandeln hätte lassen, was immer danach nach passiert wäre.
Ich glaube, das muss man noch mal festhalten, auch wenn wir es schon mal angedeutet haben. Die sportliche Leistung muss auch in einer depressiven Phase, selbst wenn es eine schwere, depressive Phase ist, nicht zwangsläufig darunter leiden. Andreas Biermann ist ein Beispiel dafür. Er lag im Trainingslager bis 5 Uhr morgens wach, weil er die Schlafstörungen hatte, die oft mit einer Depression einhergehen. Er hat trotzdem alle Trainingseinheiten, die gerade im Trainingslager besonders physisch sind, von vorne bis Ende mitgemacht. Holger Stanislavski, sein Trainer, konnte es im Nachhinein gar nicht glauben, dass er in dieser Phase so wenig Schlaf hatte und so schwer krank war, während er auf dem Platz immer noch eine Leistung gebracht hat, die absolut unauffällig in Anführungszeichen war.
Das sind hochtrainierte Sportler, die auch unter der Krankheit noch ihr Können bis zu einem gewissen Grad abrufen können. Es fällt dann keinen auf, wenn man es weiß, wenn man genau hinschaut. Als Robert tot war und als ich mir seine letzten Spiele, die er hochdepressiv bestritten hat, nochmal angeschaut hat. Wenn man das um die Krankheit weiß, dann sieht man schon, wie viel dabei ihm nicht stimmt. Zum Beispiel ein klares Symptom der Depression. Er hat nicht mehr geredet, er lief rum mit einem Gesicht, das einfach eine Maske war, auch während des Spiels. Da hat sich nichts mehr bewegt in diesem Gesicht. Das hat die komplette Gefühlslosigkeit ausgedrückt. Wie er die Bälle gehalten hat, seine Koordination war nicht mehr richtig. Er hat zwar die Bälle gehalten, aber wie er gesprungen ist, ein Arm hat zu weit gegriffen, er ist unrund abgerollt. In solchen Kleinigkeiten konnte man das schon erkennen. Martin Amedick hat mir erzählt, der Kaiserslautern hat während des Cirkel-Trainings, also einem sehr hartes Training, als er das Depressiv bestritten hat, permanent Krämpfe gekriegt. Er hat dann immer vorgetäuscht, er müsste schnell mal was trinken, eine Trinkpause machen. So ist es niemandem aufgefallen. Die können das abrufen bis zu einem gewissen Grad, aber die absolute Top-Leistung bringen sie in dem Moment nicht mehr, wenn sie unter einer schwerwiegenden Depression leiden.
Herr Dr. Henkel, Sie haben jetzt vorhin schon einmal kurz angesprochen, dass es ja auch noch diesen Wechsel gibt. Einmal haben wir gesprochen von Jugend in den Profibereich und quasi von Jugendpsychiater bis hin zu einem Erwachsenenpsychiater. Und jetzt gibt es ja aber auch noch den sportlichen Wechsel von der Karriere hin zum Karriereende. Und ich habe gelesen, dass gerade bei Männern statistisch erwiesen die Anfälligkeit für Depressionen auch oft mit dem, ich glaube, Gratifizierung nannte man das. Also wenn zum Beispiel das Ausbleiben einer Gehaltserhöhung oder eben Verabschiedung in den Ruhestand. Können wir das auch im Sport beobachten, dass Sportler, also dann Ex-Sportler, in diesen Momenten nochmal besonders anfällig sind?
Ohne Frage. Wir sehen das ja auch bei Leuten, die normalerweise im Berufsleben ausscheiden, weil sie in Rente gehen. Nur sind diese Leute meistens Mitte 60. Und so ein Sportler ist dann vielleicht Mitte 30. Und wenn er sich früh verletzt, vielleicht auch Mitte 20. Und das heißt natürlich etwas. Da verändert sich ganz viel im gesamten System. Das heißt, man kriegt nicht mehr, wie Sie sagen, diese Gratifikation, also diese Belohnung durch Sport, durch Einsätze, Nominierung, Erfolge, Siege. Man hat nicht mehr die Anerkennung vielleicht in der eigenen Familie. Man bekommt dort eine neue Rolle. Man hat jetzt plötzlich Aufgaben, die dem Alltag entsprechen und nicht mehr, sagen wir mal, so eine Nebenrolle zu Hause. Man bekommt finanzielle Änderungen. Es ist nicht häufig, viele haben keine parallele Ausbildung gemacht, und die stehen zunächst erst mal ohne Beruf da. Ganz häufig ist es so, dass sich innerhalb weniger Jahre Partnerschaften und Ehen auflösen. Und daneben kommen vielleicht Folgeerkrankungen vom Sport, chronische Schmerzen, Gelenkstörungen, also ein doch vorgealteter Körper. Und so, dass viele Dinge zusammenkommen, das ganze System ändert sich. Und das kann zum einen relativ früh passieren, weil Leistungssport nicht lange zu betreiben ist in den meisten Sportarten. Und es kann sogar ganz plötzlich kommen, von einem auf dem anderen Tag ist der Kreuzbandriss da oder eine andere schwere Verletzung und es geht nicht mehr weiter. Und da sind die wenigsten darauf vorbereitet oder man sollte sich gut darauf vorbereiten, gerade was so ein absehbares Ende betrifft. Aber nicht jeder macht sich da in jungen Alter schon Gedanken drum. Und das ist natürlich in einer wirklichen Risikokonstellation dann in der Tat dann auch hatten die Strukturen nicht mehr regelmäßiges Training, nicht mehr die selben Leute um sich herum. Man muss sich plötzlich um sowas alles selber kümmern. Und das ist in der Tat ein sehr großes Risiko.
Was tun da die Bundesliga-Vereine und auch höherklassige Amateur-Vereine, Herr Reng, um solchen Spielern zu helfen? Gibt es da schon Strukturen oder lässt man die überspitzt gesagt fallen?
Ja, der Fußballprofi ist der Angestellte des Vereins. In dem Moment, wo sein Vertrag endet, ist er nicht mehr angestellt und dann wird er verabschiedet. Es gibt Strukturen, gibt es keine. Es gibt einzelne Versuche, wie tauglich die sind, um Leuten ein neues Leben zu gestalten, ist auch fraglich. Aber es gibt jetzt mehr Traditionsvereine. Es gibt Vereine, die machen Feriencamps für Kinder und stellen dafür als Trainer alte Spieler an. Vielen Spielern im Ruhestand gibt es tatsächlich noch etwas, die Verbindung zu ihren besten Jahren, im Berufsjahren, irgendwie dabei bleiben beim Verein. Kann aber sicher nicht das Allheilmittel sein. Ich denke, bei der Mehrzahl der Spieler sollte es ja auch darum gehen, in dem Moment, wo sie aufhören, dass sie loskommen vom Fußball, dass sie etwas Neues finden. Und wenn man da Strukturen schaffen würde, ich spinne jetzt ein bisschen rum, da müsste man ja quasi eine Hochschule für Fußballer oder eine Berufsbildungsstätte für Fußballspieler schaffen. Das gibt es nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht, ob es das geben muss oder geben soll. Ich denke, das ist ja auch eine tolle Herausforderung für jeden Menschen, dass er mit 30 nochmal neu startet. Aber es ist in der Tat so. Ich glaube, ich habe in den 25 Jahren, in denen ich jetzt in der Fußballbranche arbeite, einen einzigen Fußballer getroffen. Deswegen ist es mir auch so hängen geblieben, der zu mir gesagt hat, er findet Fußballprofi ist so ein toller Beruf, weil da kann man mit 30 nochmal ganz neu anfangen. Das war ein Spieler von Bayern München, Dieter Frei hieß der. Der hat danach studiert und ist Lehrer geworden. Aber diesen Blickwinkel kann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht erwarten, dass das die Mehrheit hat. Für die Mehrheit ist Fußball der Beruf, in dem sie ihre ganze Jugend exzessiv darauf hingearbeitet haben. Es ist ein Beruf, in dem ihnen das ganze Umfeld einredet. Es sei ein Traumberuf. Und da bleibt bei den wenigsten die Zeit an etwas anderes zu denken. Und die meisten müssen sich das auf die harte Art erarbeiten. Was machen sie in den verbleibenden 60, 70 Jahren ihres Lebens?
Wäre das nicht vielleicht auch eine der Aufgaben, die der Vertragsspieler, also der VDV, übernehmen könnte? Der hat ja auch unter anderem das VDV-Profikamp, wo sich Profis fit halten können, die vertragslos sind. Müsste ja eigentlich aus dieser Richtung kommen, so ein Impuls.
Die versuchen das in der Tat mit ihren kleinen Mitteln. Die Gewerkschaft der deutschen Fußballspieler oder der Interessensverband der deutschen Fußballspieler, muss man aber auch ehrlich sagen, ist sehr schwach, was die Struktur angeht, was seine Struktur angeht, was die Gelder angeht, die ihnen zur Verfügung stehen. Also die versuchen, Sachen zu machen, bei der Berufsfortbildung Sportlern zu helfen, aber das kann immer nur ein kleiner Tropfen sein. In England zum Beispiel ist die PFA, die Professional Football Association, die Gewerkschaft der Fußballer, finanziell deutlich besser. Die können da deutlich mehr machen. Die machen zum Beispiel auch sowas, wie man leicht zynisch als Zwangssparplan bezeichnen könnte. Jeder Spieler, der in der Premier League spielt, auch wenn er aus Bulgarien kommt, zahlt einen Teil seines Gehaltes zwangsweise in eine Altersversicherung ein und die verwaltet die PFA und die wird dem Sportler dann mit 40, glaube ich, dann ausgezahlt, wenn man davon ausgeht, da ist er dann an einem Punkt, wo er eine neue Karriere starten sollte. Solche Mittel gibt es, aber im Großen und Ganzen obliegt es dann doch immer dem individuellen Fußballer, was zu machen mit seinem Leben. Wenn ich da vergleiche, so die jetzige Generation, die tatsächlich eigentlich seit sie elf, zwölf sind, in Nachwuchsleistungszentren auf diesen Sport, auf dieses Berufsziel Fußballprofi, hinarbeiten. Bei denen ist ja selbst die Schule nachrangig. Die gehen zwar zur Schule und da wird auch immer gesagt, ja, die Schule ist wichtig, aber wenn einer mit 17 vor der Profi-Karriere steht, und das habe ich bei ganz normalen Profi-Spieler, bei 1860 München erlebt, Richard Neudecker, Wittek, die spielen jetzt beide in der zweiten Liga, in Heidenheim und St. Pauli, wenn es dann Schwierigkeiten gibt in der Schule, dann wird halt das Abitur doch nicht gemacht, sondern mit 17 schon in der A-Jugend professionell gespielt. Und für die – jetzt habe ich ein bisschen ausgeholt – für die ist es, glaube ich, nochmal viel schwieriger, mit 32 etwas anderes zu machen als für die Generation vor 20, 30 Jahren, die auch immer wussten, also die schon als Jugendliche vielleicht in einem Beruf gelernt haben und die auch immer irgendwie wussten, auch wenn sie zehn Jahre Fußballprofi sind, wenn sie Glück haben, verdienen sie genug, dass sie damit einen tollen Betrieb aufmachen können, aber sie werden wieder arbeiten müssen. Und dieses Wissen haben die heutigen Spieler ja nicht. Also die vielen, viele wissen ja eigentlich, wenn sie mit dem Geld gut haushalten, dann könnte das ja sogar für ein Leben lang reichen. Nur ohne Beschäftigung, ohne die Struktur, und tagtäglich kommen dann doch viele nicht zurecht, und viele kommen auch nicht damit zurecht, ihr Geld zu verwalten. Und die Zahlen sind ja in der Tat schockierend, wie viel Fußballer Millionen verdienen und am Ende der Karriere Pfennige haben.
Woher kriegt denn die PFA in England ihr Geld? Kommt das vom Verband oder von den Spielern, von den Vereinen, von der Liga? Geld gibt es ja im Fußball.
Ja, aus Halbwissen, was zusammenreimen, ich glaube von allen Quellen. Ich meine auch, dass die Spieler auch da zwangsweise was einzahlen, was in Deutschland, wenn dann deutlich geringer der Fall ist, aber dass auch die Vereine in England deutlich höhere Abgaben zahlen. Das ist einfach eine stärkere Tradition. Also die VDV in Deutschland, der Interessensverein der deutschen Profifußballer, wurde irgendwann in den 80er- oder 90er-Jahren gegründet, meine ich. Die PFA existiert seit, weiß ich nicht, übertrieben gesagt 100 Jahren. Da steckt eine andere Kraft dahinter. Sie merken aber in England auch, gerade jetzt habe ich mit Per Mertesacker, der bei Arsenal London demnächst die Nachwuchsakademie leiten wird, übernimmt, mit dem habe ich darüber gesprochen. In England ist Fußballprofi ja auch mit 16 ein richtiger Ausbildungsberuf. Also die gehen in den Verein, so wie bei uns die Dachdecker in die Berufsschule gehen, machen die noch nebenbei Schule, aber die lernen den Beruf Fußballprofi mit 16. Und von diesen Jungs, die mit 16 Fußballprofi lernen, sind über 80 Prozent mit 18 arbeitslos und werden auch keine Anstellungen mehr in dem Beruf finden, den sie gelernt haben und müssen ganz was ganz Neues lernen. Und das ist auch etwas, was die PFA und die Premier League und der Englische Fußballverband erst jetzt begriffen haben, wie viel Hilfe und auch – da sind wir wieder beim Thema – auch psychische Unterstützung es dann für diese Jungs braucht, die ja einen Traum gelebt haben, der eigentlich die ganze Zeit bei den meisten schon eine Illusion war und die jetzt vor den Kopf gestoßen sind und ein ganz neues Leben beginnen müssen.
Was glauben Sie, woher müsste denn der Impuls in Deutschland kommen, um ein ähnliches Sicherheitsnetz aufzuziehen? Müsste das vom DFB kommen, von der DFL? Im besten Fall natürlich von beiden gemeinsam, klar.
Ich denke, in Deutschland müssten vor allem diese Tendenzen bekämpft werden, dass unser Fußballausbildungssystem immer englischer wird. Dass da immer höhere Gelder schon gezahlt werden an die Jungs im Sinne der Professionalität. Dass den Jungs unterschwellig immer mehr das Gefühl gegeben wird, die Schule ist nachrangig, sondern das müsste mehr darum gekämpft werden, was wir in Deutschland immer hatten. Also ein funktionierendes duales System, Fußballausbildung, Schulausbildung. Das war ja zum Beispiel die Nationalmannschaft. Ich meine, so um 2010 hatte eine höhere Abitursrate als der Gesellschaftsdurchschnitt in Deutschland. Das war eine fantastische Nationalmannschaft. Das zeigt, dass das eigentlich in den Jahren ab 2000, als die Nachwuchsleistungszentren erfunden wurden, bis 2012, 2013 hat das sehr gut funktioniert. Funktioniert immer noch für einen Teil der Fußballer. Aber die Tendenz ist schon in Deutschland auch zu erkennen, dass der Fußball alles andere an Bedeutung bei den Kindern schon im Alter von 15 und 16 immer mehr verdrängt. Das ist sicherlich nicht gesundheitsfördernd, auch für die Psyche.
Ich glaube auch, dass die Initiative, neben dem, dass man das strukturell von oben aufbaut, auch vor den Spielern vielleicht selber ausgehen sollte. Der VTV macht eine sehr gute Arbeit. Wenn sich mehr Spieler dort sammeln und ihre Interessen versuchen, dort zu vertreten, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man da entsprechende Initiativen starten könnte und dann vielleicht sekundär dann auch unterfüttert vielleicht mit etwas von dem Geld, was die Spieler sozusagen für andere erwirtschaften, dass man im Prinzip dann eine Struktur einfach stärkt. Ich glaube, dass der VTV da einen ganz guten Start schon macht. Ich kenne auch Herrn Baranowsky vom VTV. Die sind wirklich sehr engagiert und setzen sich dann doch zunehmend für die Interessen ein. Sie haben ja zum Beispiel aus dem Fußballcamp arbeitslose Fußballer. Es geht sicherlich auch so um Unterstützung bei Leuten, bei Spielern, die verletzt sind. Ich denke, das wäre vielleicht ein ganz guter Angriffspunkt oder ein guter Keimpunkt, aus dem raus sich sicherlich die Fußballer selber am besten auch ihre Interessenvertretung schaffen, in denen auch der Horizont über die Karriere und das Karriereende hinausgeht. Und vielleicht auch noch eine Struktur schafft, wie das dann nach dem Sport weitergehen kann.
Ja, da gibt es noch einiges zu tun. Ich habe noch mal kurz nachgeguckt. Also die PFA bekommt tatsächlich einen Großteil ihres Geldes aus den TV-Dis, der FA und der Premier League, und dann einen kleineren Teil noch durch Member-Subscriptions. Das sind dann eben auch Spieler, die sich engagieren mit dabei. So etwas Ähnliches könnte man doch auch in das.
Ja, und wenn man weiß, was dafür Summen bezahlt werden beim TV-Deal, dann ist die PFA eine ziemlich reiche Gesellschaft. In der Tat.
Ja, 24 bis 48 Millionen Pfund pro Jahr.
Richtig. Ja, die kaufen auch mal, die PFA kauft auch mal, steigert auch mal auf Kunst, bei Sosterbees auf Kunstversteigerung teure Bilder und legt ihr Geld dann in Kunst an und solche Sachen. Ich glaube, da ist die VDV in Deutschland noch deutlich davon entfernt, leider.
Ja gut, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob das das erstrebenswerte Ziel ist, in Kunst zu investieren, aber definitiv zeigt es, dass da andere Möglichkeiten bestehen als hier in Deutschland. Um diese Sendung hier so ein bisschen zum Abschluss zu bringen, würde ich Sie noch mal bitten, einmal Herr Dr. Henkel, wenn das jetzt betroffene Sportler hier vielleicht hören, und ich würde dann danach auch gerne noch mal auf Privatpersonen eingehen, nicht nur auf Sportler, aber was können denn Sportler tun, die das Gefühl haben, sie oder andere sind von Depressionen betroffen? An wen können sie sich, wohin können sie sich wenden?
Es gibt erstmal, wie gesagt, das Netzwerk, wo Sie Experten finden, wo Sie Zentren finden, die sportpsychiatrische Sprechstunden vorhalten. Auch nicht nur in Deutschland, wir haben inzwischen auch in Schweiz und in Österreich Kollegen. Und das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Es gibt daneben noch eine von der Robert-Enke-Stiftung initiierte Hotline, in der betroffene Sportler sich melden können und zunächst erstmal ein Beratungsgespräch, ein Informationsgespräch am Telefon haben können. Und wo ihnen diese Strukturen der Versorgung nahegelegt werden und wo sie schauen können, wo sie in ihrer Nähe zum Beispiel Hilfe bekommen können, was möglicherweise als nächster Ansprechpartner dort dient. Und diese Hotline ist dann fünf Tage die Woche für sechs Stunden geschaltet. Und sie ist letztlich für jeden erreichbar, entweder über die Enke-App selber oder aber halt telefonisch.
Ich werde Nummer und informative Links dazu alles auch noch in die Show Notes packen. Und wenn ich jetzt kein Sportler bin, wohin kann ich mich denn als Privatperson wenden?
Gut, diese Hotline selber wird auch von Nicht-Sportlern frequentiert. Aber natürlich, wenn jemand erkrankt ist und die Frage besteht, ob eine psychische Störung vorliegt, wären zum Beispiel der Hausarzt als früher Ansprechpartner. Oder aber halt dann, wenn die Sache klar ist in einer psychischen Erkrankung, natürlich ein niedergelassener Psychotherapeut, ein niedergelassener Psychiater oder Nervenarzt. Und es gibt natürlich je nach Krankheit Schwere, auch entsprechende stationäre Einrichtungen, Tageskliniken und da ist sicherlich der Zugang im Notfall natürlich auch jederzeit gegeben.
Ich habe bei meiner Recherche häufiger den WHO-5-Wohlfühltest oder Well-being-Index gesehen. Da soll man Fragen beantworten zum Gefühlszustand in den letzten zwei Wochen und dann gibt einem Punkteergebnis ein bisschen einen Hinweis zumindest in, ob man akut sich mal mit einem Fachmann zusammensetzen sollte. Würden Sie auch empfehlen, einen solchen Test zu wählen? Oder ist das schon so eine Sache, wo man sich dann vielleicht auch selbst belügt, wenn man ihn alleine am Monitor ausfüllt?
Ja, das ist ein grober Test mit, wie gesagt, ganz wenigen Fragen und fünf Fragen. Das kann mal ein Hinweis sein, aber das ersetzt natürlich keine Diagnose. Und auch wenn man da jetzt sozusagen nicht scoort, heißt das nicht unbedingt, dass man nicht vielleicht doch eine Depression haben könnte. Aber wichtig ist es einfach, wenn man merkt, dass etwas nicht stimmt, wenn man merkt, dass man dort wirklich krank ist, dann sollte man auch rasch die Hilfe suchen.
Und Herr Reng, was würden Sie sich wünschen? Sie sind ja auch ein Kuratorium der Robert Enke-Stiftung. Was sind so die nächsten Schritte in den nächsten Jahren, um auch im deutschen Profifußball das ganze Thema noch positiv voranzubringen?
Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist – und das ist ein vordellaufender Prozess und der wird wahrscheinlich ewig dauern – ist, dass Depressionen irgendwann eine selbstverständliche Krankheit sind. Selbstverständlich in dem Sinne nicht, dass man sagt, ah ja, du hast sie, ist ja normal und schüss und nicht behandelt. Sondern selbstverständlich in dem Sinne, dass wenn man gehört, wenn jemand im Fußballverein oder auch sonst in der Familie die Diagnose hört von einem Freund, von einer Tochter, von einem Sohn, er leidet unter Depression, dass dann diese Personen um ihn herum damit genauso viel anfangen können, wie mit Kreuzbandriss und Patella absehenden Anriss und Krippe. Also das ist einfach ein Grundwissen. Sicher nicht ein detailliertes medizinisches Wissen, aber ein Grundwissen, was sind Depressionen, welche Schritte muss ich einleiten bei der Behandlung, was sind Depressionen nicht, wie kann man nach der Depression weiterleben, dass dieses Wissen sich einfach weiterverbreitet und irgendwann dann die Leute damit so selbstverständlich umgehen, wie mit Patella-Sehnen anrissen und Kreuzbandrissen.
Ja, das ist ja das eigentlich Bizarre, dass auch ich, das gebe ich offen zu, mehr über Schambeinentzündungen wusste, weil das Ayn Robben mal so lange hatte, als über Depressionen. Aber wie man auch an mir sieht, kann man an seinem Wissen arbeiten und sich dann eine Kompetenz aufbauen. Und das mit der Schambeinentzündung wäre eigentlich viel weniger wichtig, ehrlich gesagt, für meinen Alltag, als das, was ich mir jetzt so alles angelesen habe zu diesem Thema.
Ja, also ich denke auch, weil Sie haben am Anfang ja auch gesagt, ein nicht so leichtes Thema. Ich glaube, wenn man das Wissen hat, die Leute haben ja vor allem, oder wir Menschen haben vor allem vor etwas Angst, über das wir nichts wissen. Und wenn man das Wissen hat, dann ist die Krankheit sicherlich nicht leichter zu vertragen, aber es fällt einfach leichter, damit umzugehen. Und dann ist es auch nicht mehr so schwer. Diese Schwere geben wir der Krankheit ja auch davon, weil wir vorher erstarren und davor nichts wissen wollen.
Ja, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Und natürlich auch, weil die Fälle, mit denen man sich beschäftigt, immer so extrem sind. Also ich habe jetzt, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, alle Sportlerbiografien von deutschen Sportlern gelesen. Vornehmlich Fußballern, die da betroffen waren. Das sind dann natürlich auch mal ganz extreme Schilderungen. Und das ist mir dann selber irgendwann nahe gegangen. Und da tat jetzt auch mir diese Sendung sehr gut, das Ganze mal wieder runter zu kochen auf einem normalen Maß und klarzumachen, das sind die Extremschilderungen. Und es gibt aber noch ganz, ganz viele andere Ausprägungsformen.
Ich glaube, wenn Sie eine Sendung machen würden mit zwei 44-jährigen Fußballern und die würden völlig authentisch, ohne Rücksicht Ihnen schildern, wie es Ihnen körperlich geht, das wäre nach einer 20-jährigen Karriere, ich glaube, das wäre wirklich viel, viel erschreckender. Wenn die Ihnen dann alles aufzählen würden, dann würden sie auch nicht mit zwei Stunden in Sendezeit hinkommen. Also wenn die aufzählen würden, was sie alles erlitten haben, hier Karriere von Kapselriss bis abgerissenes Ohr und die Nase gebrochen beim Ellbogencheck und wie es Ihnen jetzt geht. Also die körperlichen Schicksale von Fußballern sind deutlich weit verbreiteter und schwerwirkender, werden aber banalisiert im Fußball.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns klar machen, dass Leid auch immer individuell ist und es gar keinen Sinn macht zu vergleichen, dass was der eine als nicht so schlimm empfindet, kann für den anderen sehr unangenehm sein. Zum Beispiel Schmerzwahrnehmung oder wie gesagt aber auch Depressivität. Ich glaube, man erfährt ja von den Betroffenen selber, wie sehr ihnen etwas beeinträchtigt, wie sehr darunter leidet. Das sollte man auch wahrnehmen und nicht relativieren oder vergleichen. Ich glaube, was die Emotionen, wie jemand damit umgeht, mit Symptomen, die nicht funktionieren, mit ausgeschlossen sein, das kann sozusagen großes Leid verursachen und ist einfach nicht skalierbar, sondern individuell manchmal sehr bedeutend.
Ja, völlig richtig. Meine Herren, vielen herzlichen Dank für die Zeit. Das waren zum einen Dr. Karsten Henkel, Oberarzt an der Uniklinik Aachen und Facharzt für Psychiatrie und Psychotherapie. Er hat unter anderem die sportpsychiatrische Sprechstunde gemacht. Jetzt wissen wir alle, was das eigentlich ist. Vielen Dank, Herr Dr. Henkel, für Ihre Zeit.
Danke für die Möglichkeit, auch sozusagen etwas über die Depression weiterzugeben und ein bisschen mehr Bewusstsein und Sensibilität zu schaffen.
Ich hoffe, es ist auf fruchtbaren Boden bei meinen Hörern und Hörern gefallen. Ich gehe aber fast davon aus. Und ebenso großer Dank. Vielen Dank an Ronald Reng, der unter anderem das Buch zu Robert Enke geschrieben hat, ganz viele andere tolle Fußballbücher auch. Herr Reng, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für die Zeit, die Sie sich genommen haben. Und damit dann auch Dank an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das bis hierhin gehört haben und die vielleicht sogar den Rasenfunk unterstützen. Der Rasenfunk ist werbefrei, sponsorenfrei. Und irgendwann möchte ich auch mal meinen Gästen, gerade wenn ich so tolle Gäste habe wie in dieser Sendung, ein Honorar zahlen können. Dazu braucht es noch ein bisschen mehr finanzielle Unterstützung von euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Alle Informationen findet ihr dazu auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn diese Folge hier Verbreitung findet und vielleicht auch dem einen oder anderen dann ja vielleicht auch selbst weiterhilft. Das würde mich sehr freuen. In diesem Sinne vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in einem der nächsten Tribünengespräche oder einer der nächsten Schlusskonferenzen. Kurzpässe gibt es auch noch. Liebe Hörer, macht's gut, bis bald, tschüss! Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.